good afternoon and welcome to nature's
returns investing in ecosystem services
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for Business on environment
my name is Karina Mahone and I will be
your host for this afternoon's
presentation titled bright spots for
resource mobilization regional
initiatives the Yale Center for business
and the environment cbay is pleased to
announce the continuation of nature's
returns a webinar series that addresses
the growing in importance of ecosystem
services evaluation and investment each
presentation is recorded and available
on the deal I use you channel in today's
webinar we will explore to regional
finishes the micronesia to college and
the Harvey initiative regional models
for leveraging large scale probably an
hypothesis toward by the protection and
then I always is hospital workers
because today we'll highlight in a ling
ling masters as the support regional
travis has a final vehicles to a truck
and provide long-term sustainable
funding for biodiversity conservation
they will also detail how countries
within their respective regions have
capitalized on their natural resources
to generate revenue for the trust funds
yeah bannocks Bautista is a chief
executive officer of the Caribbean
biodiversity fund a Caribbean regional
endowment fund whose objective is to
support activities that contribute to
the conservation protection and
maintenance of biodiversity within the
National protected areas systems or any
other areas of environmental
significance of its participating
countries Willie Kostka is a co-founder
of the micronesia Conservation Trust in
which he currently serves as executive
director William is currently involved
in implementation of the micronesia
challenge initiative a common commitment
by
countries and territories of Micronesia
to a comprehensive system of resilient
protected areas networks this regional
partnership has supported work at
approximately 150 sites across the
region and raised more than 30 million
dollars for conservation work across
Micronesia finally we would like to
remind our listeners that we welcome any
questions you may you might have and we
will direct them to our speakers at the
conclusion of the talk you can type
questions directly into the gotomeeting
chat window and with that we welcome ya
binocs Batista and will Acosta to
nature's returns we will start off with
ya binocs thank you very much currently
video to participate in this upper um
most welcome to all the fans that are
here um today I hope you can all see my
presentation is is it showing correctly
Karina yes we can see if you can go
ahead about thank you thank you very
much so again thank you very much
everyone is really a true pleasure to be
here with you today in this webinar it's
amazing what technology can do and today
I will share with you the experience of
the Caribbean biodiversity fund as a
financial mechanism as a sustainable
financial mechanism for the Caribbean
challenge initiative and I may I also
want to to share with you that in fact
the Caribbean challenge initiative and
the Caribbean biodiversity fund our
sister initiatives and institutions of
the micronesia challenge and the
micronesia Conservation Trust will talk
about and we in our region in the
Caribbean were very much inspired by
what happened in Micronesia before our
time so it's really a pleasure to be
sharing the stage today with with Willy
um in my presentation today I will focus
on my list I'll talk to you briefly
about what is the the CBF its objectives
and what is the Caribbean challenge
initiative and how the CBF and the CCI
are related and then on the second part
as this is very much about resources
mobilization the objective of the
webinar I will talk more about the CBF
how we are structured as a fund how the
flow of resources work and I'll also
give you a little bit of information
about our current status in terms of
financing fundraising and then resources
mobilization um absolute already written
by Trina the CBF sabino endowment fund
um and our objective is to be as a
sustainable source of funding that would
support conservation in for the
protected area systems and other areas
of environmental significance of the CBF
participating countries a little bit
i'll explain whoo-hoo-hoo exactly we
support as you can see in our mission
statement of purpose statement we have a
very broad objective that would allow us
to finance projects in different areas
related to environment conservation be
in terrestrial marine conservation but
also on things related to sustainable
fisheries to climate change adaptation
and mitigation sustainable tourism and
natural resource management and the
definition of our purpose in this broad
scale was done in purpose because there
are different priorities in different
countries that that we support and we
wanted to make sure we could provide the
support that everyone needed these files
our objective c BF also aims to assist
countries in general to achieve the
commitments that they have a deer to in
the convention on biological diversity
as some of you may know countries have
signed up to the CBD and and there are
targets to be achieved in terms of
creation of protected areas and how
these
that areas should be managed and the CBD
commitments also talk about resources
mobilization floor for four at the
national level I all at the regional
level and the CBD sees itself as a
mechanism that also helps to attract
those resources but also make sure that
the commitments are fulfilled we expect
the series lead commitments the
Caribbean the Caribbean by diversity
fund also aims to help the countries
that have voluntarily adhere to the
Caribbean challenge initiative to
fulfill those commitments the CDC I
commitments or Caribbean challenge
initiative commitments are all around
marine resources protection and
conservation and I'll talk a little bit
more in a little while about the
Caribbean challenge initiative excited
VDS cci we also aim to support countries
in achieving commitments under the
united nations framework convention on
climate change in particular in topics
related to how to use natural solutions
on water mitigation and adaptation to
climate change and last but not least as
many of you probably also know there is
a huge conservation finance gap um all
around the world and this basically
means that we don't have enough
resources and a disposal available to
food to really finance conservation
properly in most countries around the
world and this is quite a critical area
for small island developments
development States not only in the
Caribbean but also in the Indian Ocean
and in the Pacific and our countries
normally have huge financial gaps in
terms of conservation and the CBF aims
to be a mechanism that will help and
assist countries in closing that
financial gap I'm botanics to all of
those overall objectives we also hope
that that by establishing what we call a
sustainable finance architecture for the
Caribbean which is composed of the CBF
Plus also sister trust funds at the
national level which we will support we
hope that we will increase the the
profile of environment as environments
often overlooked and in our region and
to also increase the resources as I
mentioned before available for
conservation as they're very few overall
and also increase the priority for
environment politically and in reality
for society in general often environment
ministry's are the least funded
ministries in our countries and in terms
of political priorities environment
normally takes one of the last positions
as well but for for our Islands the
environment is critical because our
economies our tourism industries often
depend from those very same natural
resources so the idea is that these
sustainable finance architecture will
help provide the resources for for
better managing those resources that
support our national economies and also
increase the voice of environment in the
region a little bit more about the
Caribbean challenge nation the Caribbean
challenge initiative was launched at the
CD conference of the parties in 2008 in
Bonn Germany it was launched by for
governments Bahamas Grenada the
dominican republic and jamaica and this
initiative basically has established two
main goals and those are the effective
protection and conservation of twenty
percent of the nearshore marine
ecosystems by 2020 of those countries
that that allowing to this initiative
and also creating as i mentioned before
the sustainable finance architecture for
conservation in the region this
sustainable finance architecture is
composed of two key layers the first one
is a regional layer which is represented
by the caribbean biodiversity fund which
is the fund i represent and the other
layer the second layer is the national
level trust funds that are currently
being established in the eighth part
the painting countries of the CBF by
creating these institutions and
establishing these institutions and
remixes before in our countries we both
as I've mentioned before to increase the
flow of resources for conservation in
the region and help the countries
achieve the 20 by 20 target of the Civic
cci brabant challenge initiative as well
as other environmental objectives how
was the Caribbean how did the Caribbean
challenge initiative originated well um
even before 2008 if official launch
government's already have started to
realize that the economies of the
Caribbean islands depends very much on
the natural resources that we have our
coral reefs our issues our mangroves our
fisheries and that is for tourism
industry for local livelihoods but for
everything it creates a lot of direct
and indirect employment and and
governments have increasingly paid more
attention to this so that was a great
the first and most important impetus for
the government's to to come together and
and join in the Caribbean challenge
initiative because they know they depend
on this um then we besides that it was
not only the political will that was
necessary you also needed partners to
come to the table to help the countries
financially to start the process so a
number of dollars which you will see
later and partners have come to the
table and because the countries have
committed to reaching those goals that I
explained before the partners and the
donors um have decided that they want to
assist the countries and help the
countries achieve those goals because
they have shown that they have political
will to do sir so those are two of the
key ingredients in the genesis of the
Caribbean challenge initiative and the
Caribbean why diversity in this next
slide you see a quick diagram map of all
the countries that are part of the
Caribbean challenge initiative and the
premium biodiversity fun there is no
direct correlation kind of one-to-one
correlation but in the red circle you
see the cci countries and the yellow
stars are the countries that will
benefit yes there are some observer
countries or countries that want to join
the the CBF and those are for the reco
and British Virgin Islands which usually
the empty yellow stars the the 6p i
commenced were were reaffirmed during a
summit of political and business leaders
that took place in May 2013's summit to
place in the British Virgin Islands and
brought together um eight environment
minister made first from from the region
with you see now on your screen and
these leaders find the leaders
declaration which we affirm the two
balls than I mentioned for twenty right
on target and the creation of the
sustainable finance architecture then
there were also 15 companies that signed
the corporate compact which it's a
compact that the in which these
companies commit themselves to also
provide resources to help this country's
achieve the targets on the around the
cci the critical challenge initiative
and also improve their there where
social environmental corporate
responsibility on Linden and third there
were about 30 partners partners that
also attended the summit and committed
around 75 million dollars of in projects
that were currently in being implemented
or that were going to be coming online
and that were also aligned those
projects to achieving the goals of the
Caribbean challenge those partners
included bilateral organizations and so
far bilateral annexations I mean
government aid from from other countries
like Germany the UK Italy also for
multilateral institutions to my favorite
the information in the World Bank d e f
and unep the united nations environment
program and development program and also
from from NGOs and foundations like the
Nature Conservancy and old foundation
now the Caribbean challenge initiative
had story its second phase after that
summit and usually in your in your
screens what that second phase is going
to entail now we are we are we are
particularly advancing a lock on the
last bullet point which is achieving and
creating that sustainable finance
architecture and that's what I'm going
to focus on in the rest of my
presentation the stevia how does it work
in this screen um you see a lot of boxes
and then I asked in a minute here or so
explaining our whole organization and I
mean pension funds but in the middle you
see the box that we possess the CBF and
it's a boring as our bank account and
our institution at the same time our
secretary on the top you see the
donations coming from from the donors
our current dollars are the German
Development Bank the Nature Conservancy
and the global environment facility for
42 million dollars to date for our face
one translation of those 42 million
dollars 28 have been deposited and we
have already gained income and runnin
down the values 30 million dollars the
left of the screen you see that we are
governed by a board of directors these
more of directors is currently the first
German the moment bank and the nation
Conservancy and country observers from
the eight countries that are going to
benefit from the CDF I also see the
Secretariat that's the office I need and
then to the right you see that we have
established our basic operations and
have our conference our investment
managers we work with our partners we
have our part why it's important to
mention all this particularly the
accounting the auditors and the
investment managers because it's a
financing institution we are a finance
institution it's very important for our
donors and our partners and our we're
sticking to know that we have a very
solid basis on which we are investing
our resources and
now you have clear rules of accounting
interference e so that all information
is available and very clear to everyone
at the bottom you see eight boxes that
represent the National Conservation
Trust Funds that would benefit from the
CPF and as I mentioned these trust funds
are being phablet at the moment and once
those trust funds are established via
look basically the front track those
institutions they receive support from
us at the same time when we sign that
contract those trust funds out of their
board membership their individual board
membership they would be able to select
a person that would represent that trust
fund in the CBF bored and that's why to
the left you see a line that connects
those eight boxes to the board of
directors of the CBF so that is a basic
explanation and initial explanation and
I'm happy to entertain questions later
on this on how the CBF works and how our
governance works in terms of finance
thing here there you see a lot of
numbers in this lied but it's just to
show how we are also organized
financially so we have eight countries
in our books with three donors at the
moment we hope to add more and each of
the countries has a sub-account within
our endowment and different donors
provide different amounts of support to
those sub accounts as you see about 42
million dollars have been flesh and in
the numbers in parentheses at the bottom
you see the totals amount that that have
been deposited today in the very very
near future hoping in the next year you
will be able to have the full deposits
for the 42 million dollars in the CBF
endowment once we we have all these
resources and once we enter into a
contract with the trust funds that we
are going to support the CBF
out of its capital gains when we
generate from interest from our
investments those are the resources that
we are going to use to support the trust
funds at the national levels so the idea
is that for the CBF to be a sustainable
mechanism for conservation we cannot use
our capital base we have to use only our
the interest that we earn the income we
earn and that's what we are going to
distribute and that's how we would be
building the sustainability aspect
financially in this case here is the
it's a graph in which you see an initial
on them for the period of September 2013
to August 2014 on how the CDF endowment
value has behaved this this is a very
short period of time to show how how the
CBF investments have reacted to to our
investment strategy and to calm markets
behave but in the future I hope I'm
making a future webinar I would be able
to give you an update on how the CBF has
done financially and how effective our
investment strategy has been and show
how how the endowment has behaved here I
think it's important to also mention
that the CBF has an investment strategy
which target is to have a seven percent
return on investment annually and this
return on investment target we achieved
it last year we hope that we will
achieve it in this year as well and we
would be using we will be using about
five percent of those so five percent of
the of the return on investment of that
for for making payments to the trust
funds and then the rest and and to
support my office the operations of my
office and then the rest is going to be
reinvested in the sub accounts of each
country one important principle of the
CBF is that while we are going to
provide assistance to the countries and
the natural trust funds to help achieve
commitments by diversity and close the
financial gap the CBF will also later on
in the relationship which trucks one
require a one-to-one match because part
of our objective as well is to increase
the overall size of the pie for
conservation and I think I'm having a
little bit of a technical glitch here I
think you can still see my screen I
think you can um and and this
requirement for having a one-to-one
match the idea is that the stakeholders
at the country level will create a meal
mechanisms that would direct new money
to the National Conservation Trust Funds
that will also benefit from the CBF so
again the idea is to increase the amount
of resources that go to conservation and
these two options can can range from
from being purely government options in
terms of the sustainable finance
mechanisms and or being purely private
but the truth is that most likely it's
going to be a mix it's going to be
everything that it's in the gray zone
and of course these options will vary
from from country to country I'm how
significant is the funding that will be
provided by the CBF so once we have all
of our funding deposited in our
accountant and assuming all the trust
funds are established and operational we
will be providing close to two million
dollars per year to all these trust
funds together and once all the matching
mechanisms are established and they
fulfill the one-to-one match we would be
generating in together about 3.75
million dollars a year
is quite significant for the countries
particularly because it's going to be in
perpetuity and in some cases it's going
to help close by ten to fifteen percent
the conservation financial gap in each
country we also hope that in the future
the CBF capital will continue to grow
and that we will open other types of
funding windows and also do this for men
to build least a number of procedures to
declare trust funds at the national
level eligible for CBS support and we're
currently working on that and that we
also provide guidance and support these
trust funds in terms of how they should
be structured to make sure that they
follow internationally recognized
standards on how conservation trust
funds work the CBF for example is part
of the Latin American network I'm latin
america and caribbean network of
conservation trust funds and our aim is
to support the trust funds in the
caribbean as well in making sure that
they are sound institutions and both
financially but also in terms of their
conservation objectives um last i wanna
i'm going to run quickly as i know time
is running short but i just wanted to
give you a glimpse into the future of
the CBF and we are currently working on
a strategic plan that will take this to
2020 and this plan basically the
objective would be to provide a vision
for the CBF and the role we should play
in the region through 2020 and we we
have about five main focus areas first
is establishing a strong operational
institutional foot for for the CBF
continue to strengthen the relations and
engagement with the government and
regional actors designing and
establishing new thematic windows for
funding right now the CBF has a
biodiversity protection and conservation
window which yes allows for other kind
of supports related to climate change
and fisheries but what we would like to
do in the future is to have at least
three windows that would also
specifically to additional windows that
would cover specifically specifically
climate change
saleable fisheries for we we are looking
at expanding the geographic scope of the
CBF a number of countries are interested
in joining the CBF those are Haiti
Puerto Rico British Virgin Islands US
virgin islands on Barbados they they
have expressed in some way or another an
interest in joining the CBF and then
also we we need to work very much on a
CBS Face to fundraising strategy we
still have to establish a goal for our
fundraising strategy and last and but
not least we are going to be working for
the strategic plan as well in
establishing and implementing a
marketing a communication strategy and I
think with that I I thank you again for
for your participation for your
attention and I look forward to your
questions towards the end of the seminar
thank you again green thanks very much
yellow now we're going to direct the
talk to Willie Kostka of the micronesia
Conservation Trust he will talk about
his regional initiative and the work
within that region willing let's make
we can get Willie online are you hearing
no no you mean we can go right ahead
Willie Thank You Korina so the
micronesia Conservation Trust which was
established in 2002 became part of the
Micronesia challenge initiative which
was a commitment by the governments of
the Federated States of Micronesia
Republic of Palau Marshall Islands and
the US territories of guam in CNMI
basically the magnesia challenge
initiative is to set aside under
effective protection thirty percent of
our near shore marine resources and
twenty percent of our tertiary sources
by 2020 when the leaders made the
decision and the commitment to after
magnesia challenge they selected the
mechanism Conservation Trust to be the
financing mechanism for the endowment
that they sought to establish as part of
the Micronesia challenge initiative the
idea and based off of a sustainable
financing plan that we worked on which
determined that we would need
approximately 56 million dollars in an
endowment to support the cap from what
was left of the budgets of governments
and the local organizations that are
working on conservation in Micronesia
and so the each of the countries have
been working to put funding into the
mekinese a challenge endowment fund
which is being managed by the mechanism
Conservation Trust we at the moment the
endowment is around 18 million dollars
again the call is to raise fifty six
million dollars
for the endowment in addition to the
establishment of the endowment the
countries are also seeking to establish
national and local sustainable financing
mechanisms in Palau they've created
green fee which is collected from all
visitors to Palau at fifteen dollars per
visitor and that's bringing in
approximately 1.5 million dollars per
year to support their protected areas
network the Federated States of
Micronesia Republic of Marshall Islands
Guam and Sienna Maya are also looking at
establishing their own tourism or
visitor fees to go into their own
national sustainable financing mechanism
but they're also looking at other things
such as adding a resource management fee
to the tuna fisheries especially for the
fsm and of Marshall Islands which would
again go into their own national
financing mechanisms the the seed
funding for the for the endowment came
from the global environment facility and
also at 5.1 million dollars and then
both the Nature Conservancy and
Conservation International each provided
three million dollars to the endowment
the endowment is divided by the
countries and it the amount that the
country's put in including the
commitments that the global environment
facility CI and tnc put in makes up each
country's total amount so
at the moment a republic of palau and
dominant amount is just over eight
million dollars for the Federated States
of Micronesia is about five million
dollars and for the Republic of the
Marshall Islands about four million
dollars the earnings from those at five
percent will be going out to the
countries to help support the protected
area networks in each of those countries
in addition to the larger regional
endowment and the national financing
mechanisms that they're coming up with
we've also sought to work with
individual sites to or individual
islands to create other sustainable
financing mechanisms for example in the
state of Koschei in the Federated States
of Micronesia the we've started the
first conservation easement in the
Pacific with a small five hundred twenty
thousand dollar endowment for the ten
landowners on the island of ko Sai for a
special forest of the remaining
terminalia forests in that stage and the
dividends from the endowment are then
provided to the to the landowners in
return for giving up development rights
for their their land other things such
as revolving ones that we're also
starting to help farmers establish
conservation work in in their own areas
we've also been working
on the first payment for ecosystem
services mechanism in island of Pohnpei
to have a water fund that would provide
funding to those landowners who own the
areas around the our main headwaters
that supply water to over sixty percent
of the island's population the idea is
to track on half a sense where thousand
gallons and that would generate
approximately four hundred thousand
dollars on an annual basis which would
be used for managing the forest around
the areas that provide water to again
sixty percent of the population of
pumping so those are the types of
financing mechanisms that we're working
on we have the larger regional endowment
which the mechanistic Conservation Trust
is managing and then we have national
mechanisms that are that the countries
themselves have put in place and then we
also have those local financing
mechanisms that are directed at specific
sites or at at the state level the the
way that the Micronesia challenge
endowment fund is going to operate is
that the the earnings at no more than
five percent would be provided to the
financing mechanism the national
financing mechanisms which are being
called the protected areas Network funds
will receive the interests that are made
on the key endowment and they would then
distribute those
funds to the sites as to the protected
areas at in each national and and
territorial area so that's where we are
I am going to stop here and allow for
some questions from our moderators Thank
you Thank You Willie as a reminder we
encourage our viewers to submit
questions in the chat section and we
will be directing those towards the
speakers but just to start the
discussion off both Yvonne relief please
feel free to answer how have the
regional trust funds been able to
encourage both government and private
sector investment in nature to generate
returns for conservation and what have
been the limitations of this particular
structure in achieving this particular
goal go ahead Willie thank you all
Sanderson Thank You Korina the for the
Micronesia region we've really struggled
to have a private input into the into
the endowments we we don't have any
private company input we've we've worked
with the government's and donor
organizations to provide the funding
that goes into the endowments
unfortunately for us we still have
haven't cracked the or or have the
ability to be able to entice or bring in
private sector investment into the into
the endowment now with the with the
government's the way that it's work is
when we're able to for example get
commitments from
vation international the Nature
Conservancy and the global environment
facility and requiring a one-to-one
match from the government that's allowed
or has been a good way to get government
governments to put up their own funds
into the endowment without those
commitments from donors outside it it
will be very difficult for the countries
themselves to to meet the requirements
or the needs as identified in the
sustainable financing plan so it works
both ways we have when we get interest
from international donor organizations
they're able to get our local
governments or national governments to
get excited about providing funding
because they know it would be matched as
well as when the government's themselves
are able to put in money then that gives
the international donors peace of mind
and security that they would their money
is going into an endowment that the
government's care about so it worked it
works both ways thank you karina in the
in the case of the caribbean terms of
the private sector we do have a much
wider spectrum of of companies different
private sector institutions that are
engaged in the region we have a lot of
tourism cargo shipments etc etc but um
we also have some difficulties in
tapping into this into this sector for a
few reasons first tourism vendors or
companies hotels all those all those
actors they want to try to provide the
cheapest product as possible often to to
the tourists and they feel that by
by engaging in initiative like this and
providing resources that may make their
products more expensive I'm luckily we
do see a lot of actors that are a lot
more progressive and forward-looking and
they understand that their product
depends on a good national research base
so we are trying in brigantine to start
working with rose um actors and I think
a good initial step was the comfort
corporate compact I will sign at the
Caribbean challenge initiative summit
there's still a long way to go engaging
with the with with Airlines and cruise
ships and restaurants and hotels it's
complex because they are big companies
and and it is a it is a dialogue that
has to take a long time to make sure
that all parties and stakeholders feel
comfortable with what what it's being
gone and that's just the nature of our
things like this um so it takes a lot of
time and effort but we will achieve that
in terms of the government's I think
like Willie was saying that the
government commitment is quite important
and as I mentioned in my presentation
and Willie mentioned convince the fact
that in building the micronesia
challenge and the Caribbean challenge
the government's make commitments to
conservation that actually helped to
bring donors to live without those
commitments without that political will
the gef we were teen scene German
Development Bank in the case of the
Caribbean would have come to people and
and and it is important to keep that
commitment from the countries in place
and sometimes it's difficult to do that
because we go through election um cycles
and presidents or prime minister stream
and and we need to to keep working with
the new leadership in different
countries to make sure that those
commitments are kept so it is always is
just having the signature of a leaders
declaration in the summit is not enough
it is it is a job that we have to keep
doing every day and by mentioning
will you mentioned also in his remarks
now I'm establishing the sustainable
finance mechanisms and the national
level also requires not only engaging
with the private sector political public
sector and to create those partnerships
it is an ongoing job and a challenging
one and we we all try to make it
rewarding is that it's not easy maybe in
the presentations it sounds easy but
it's quite challenging great thank you
for your sponsors will enable we have a
question from an audience member the
question is can you address how these
two initiatives have collaborated and
shared ideas are there other similar
efforts in other regions maybe we can
have Willie start this Thank You Korina
well when we started the Micronesia
challenge just after a few years or a
couple of years of trying to implement
the magnesia challenge we were invited
by the Nature Conservancy to talk to the
folks in Caribbean about this initiative
and that actually helped to spur the
Caribbean challenge and today we have we
have the western Indian Ocean challenge
which was also spurred by the magnet
challenge and the Caribbean challenge
and the Coral Triangle initiative as
well so but in terms of collaboration
with the other the other initiatives
we've been working through the global
island partnership in getting you know
these initiatives moving forward in
learning from each other with the
lessons that we're learning in each of
the image of the initiatives we've been
able to get
a lot of support from our partners in
the global environment facility and
thought that support comes to all the
initiatives and the lessons learned are
being shared with all the organizations
that are part of these initiatives in in
several instances instances where there
have been international international
meetings or forums we've joined with the
other initiatives the other challenges
and we've held presentations together
and from those we also learn from each
other thank you oh great thanks Willie
we have a specific question directed to
Yabba the question is how can a country
become a new member of the Caribbean by
diversity fund and what is the
approximate timeline for this process
also will if you'd like you can probably
address this question for the Micronesia
Conservation Trust once yaba has
provided his response Thank You Korina
and that's actually a really excellent
question um basically for a country to
to become part of the CBF to receive
support from the CBF we need two key
ingredients the first one is that we
need a an interest from from that
country the stakeholders in that country
often the initial interest um comes from
from the government particularly the
Ministry of Finance and or the Ministry
of Environment and we start a process of
an informal dialogue on to discuss what
is the CBF how is it that the country
understands the workings of the CBF and
to make sure that we are all on the same
page at the same time the funding that
we currently have in the CBF from the
donors it's earmarked for the current
age countries that participate in the
CBF so if another country is going to
join the CBF
I also need to work together with the
country in getting new donors that would
support that particular country because
I cannot use the knowledge that I have
earmarked by other countries for a new
country so in something this discussion
that that we are some of the four to
five countries that are interested in
joining the syriac Indonesia and my hope
is that since we are doing this initial
batch of countries eight countries ours
hopefully in the next year year and a
half we will formalize the relationship
with all these eight trust funds in the
in the eighth participating countries
I'm once we do that we will have a much
a lot of know-how and I hope that in a
period of a year 22 i would say probably
two years to three years we can complete
the whole process and that sounds like a
lot like a long time but when you look
at how these initiatives and how these
institutions are our need to be
established two to three years is it's
actually not that long the Caribbean
challenge initiative and the CBF those
conversations on creating the CBF and
the cci started in 2006 we're in 2014
now so so working on all this takes a
long long time and you have to be
persistent so my hope is that we will
have a lot of lessons learned and ways
on how to expedite the processing so
that more countries can enjoy I hope I
answered the marina and whoever made it
thank you yes thank you ya bah Oh Willie
yeah for micronesia the countries are
already part of the micronesia challenge
it's it's just a matter of working with
them to develop their endowments and
their financing and their national
financial mechanism so but in in terms
of how countries are going to be
receiving their the earnings from their
endowments from the
from mct we are working with them to
develop financing mechanisms at the
national level that can receive and
disperse these funds and those are most
likely going to be the protected area
network funds in each country and we're
also working with them to develop what
we're calling country program as
strategies which identify you know what
are the types of activities and programs
that funds can quote awards and what
activities and programs that the fund
cannot go to work so that's what we're
currently working on thank you so we
sure go right ahead quickly to my to my
answer and that is that the the idea is
that we would also have a roadmap
together so we would work on
establishing a road map with that
country so that we establish the steps
in the key out country being able to
become a CDF participating we have one
more question from an audience member
and then we will probably wrap up the
webinar so the question is these CBDs
resource mobilization is also about
putting biodiversity high on the
national agenda in other words they seek
to integrate biodiversity as a priority
for sectoral policies do the presented
models help achieve this systemic change
and have an impact on the national
development plans and when I say CBD for
those online they are referring to the
convention on biological diversity so we
could probably start with you yabo Thank
You Korina and thank you for that
question it is an excellent question I
think this year is also particularly
important for that topic as we are soon
approaching the UN
assembly where the sustainable
development goals are going to be
discussed and then right after that we
have the climate change meeting in Paris
and often in these four are the
discussion also includes how
biodiversity is integrated into
sustainable development and climate to
accelerate Sarah um so the short answer
is yes and it is the definitely intent
of the of the CCI the Caribbean
challenge initiative and the Caribbean
biodiversity fun as a financial
mechanism to work for the CCI to help
raise the voice of biodiversity in the
development agenda of our countries as I
mentioned our economies depend very much
on that natural resource base and also
but we are seeing in the process of the
establishment of the National
Conservation Trust once in each of the
eight participating countries as the CDF
is that many of those trust funds are
going to go beyond pure biodiversity
conservation they just wanna they want
to make sure that these funds can
address issues related to sustainable
development including climate change
land degradation so many countries are
thinking along these lines and that is
also going to help raise raise the voice
of conservation and biodiversity and
development agenda and I think that is a
very positive sign because often in our
countries they're very few for through
which the environment can can raise its
voice and and the idea is that these
National Conservation Trust ones will be
strong institutions that will be a flag
to they will be able to raise the
biodiversity flag but also insert that
discourse and that that dialogue within
the broader development school so that's
definitely the aim that we thank you
thank you thank you for your response
Willie
Thank You Korina for the Micronesian
countries the they've developed their
sustainable development goals and and
those calls at the national levels to
include biodiversity as part of those
sustainable development goals and and
climate change and so yes they are very
important for the for the country's the
the countries have identified tourism
fisheries and aquaculture I mean
agriculture as part of their development
goals for the coming years and and in
all those three it requires you know
working on mainstreaming biodiversity
conservation into national plans and so
that's where we are today some of the
countries have already started those
plans are moving forward and and and
we're part of it as the financial
mechanism for the micronesia challenge
great thank you for your response and
with that we will conclude our talk on
bright spots for resource mobilization
regional initiatives we would like to
thank ya binocs Bautista and Willie
Kostka for joining us this afternoon if
you would like to view a recording of
this webinar please visit the Yale
Center for business and the environment
website or access the recording through
the Yale iTunes University podcast
series this is Karina mahone from the
Yale Center for business and the
environment saying so long from New
Haven Connecticut thank you for joining
us